>> Greg: GINA DAVIS IS IN NO
HURRY TO FORGIVE BILL MURRAY BUT
CAN WE TRUST HER WHEN SHE
CONDEMNS OUR FAVORITE
GHOSTBUSTERS.
ACTRESS GINA DAVIS SAYS THAT
SHE'S NEVER GOTTEN OVER THE WAY
MIA MURRAY TREATED HER ON 71990
MOVIE.
IF YOUR MEMBER THAT MOVIE NO ONE
DOES.
A BOMB SO HARD IT MADE ICE IS
JEALOUS.
ON THE BACK AS DAVIS SAID THAT
SHE AND MURRAY WERE ABOUT TO
SHOOT A SCENE AT A MANHATTAN
INTERSECTION AND SHE WASN'T SURE
IF SHE WAS GOING TO COME TO THE
SET OR NOT.
WHEN PRESSED OFF BILL MURRAY
BUSTED INTO A TRAILER RAN CLOWN
COSTUME.
UNDER OF RAGE WAS COMING OUT OF
HIS EYEBALLS.
>> RAGE COMING OUT OF HIS
EYEBALLS AND START SCREAMING AT
ME AND SCREAMING AT ME WHAT THE
[BLEEP] COME UP THE [BLEEP] ARE
YOU DOING MOVE, MOVE.
HE GOT BEHIND ME AND SCREAMED MY
YEAR MOVE FASTER, MOVE IT.
GOING INTO THE INTERSECTION
WHERE THERE'S HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
AND KEEPS UP AND KEEPS IT UP.
HE SAID STAND THERE AND POINTS
TO A MARK ON THE PAVEMENT AND
START SHOOTING.
IT SOUNDS BAD.
BUT BE HAPPY IT WASN'T
ALEC BALDWIN.
[LAUGHTER]
I HAVE TO GO TO KAT BECAUSE I
WORK WITH EVERY DAY.
I LISTEN TO THIS AND I SAID
THEREFORE THAT'S ME I DEFEND
BILL MURRAY SHE IS AN IDIOT.
RIGHT?
GIVE US THE UNDERSTAND IS NO
REASON TO TAKE YOUR TIME AND
TELEVISION.
THERE'S NO REASON HE WAS IN A
CLOWN COSTUME HE'S IN THE MIDDLE
OF THIS AND SHE IS SITTING IN
HER TRAILER OF COURSE SHE'S
COULD BE PASSED.
WHAT SAY YOU?
YOU SEE ME EVERY DAY THE VERY
SAME WAY.
>> Kat: NO, YOU'RE WORSE.
YOU ARE WORSE BECAUSE HE WENT TO
GO GET HER HIMSELF.
IT'S MY TURN OKAY?
WHAT YOU DO IS YOU BEGIN TO YELL
AT EVERYONE AROUND YOU WHO IS
THERE WISE AND THIS PERSON HERE
YET, WHY DIDN'T YOU TELL THEM
THAT THEY NEEDED TO BE HERE AT
THIS TIME?
YOU YELL AT THOSE PEOPLE AND
THEN THEY RUN TO GO GET THE
PERSON AND WHEN A PERSON COMES
IN THEN YOU YELL AT THEM.
HE ALSO ONE PERSON, YOU GOT AT
LEAST SEVEN.
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
>> Greg: BUT EVERYONE SHOULD
WELCOME A YOUNG BECAUSE HE GETS
EVERYBODY HOME SOONER.
THAT'S MY WHOLE GOAL IS SO
EVERYONE CAN GET HOME TO THEIR
LOVED ONES.
TYRUS?
>> Tyrus: HAS EVERYTHING TO DO
WITH HIS BARBECUE OKAY KRISTA
MARK HE GETS HUNGRY AND LITTLE
GREG GETS NASTY.
HE'S LIKE A LITTLE ANGRY DOG
WHEN HE DOESN'T GET HIS MEAL ON
TIMES THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
I NEED TO EAT.
I SHOULD SIGNATURE BACK ON THIS
ONE.
BECAUSE IT'S OPEN SEASON
BILL MURRAY I WILL TRY TO FIND
SOME A GO AT.
BEING A FEW MOVIES WHEN YOU GET
TO TRAILER YOU HAVE A LITTLE
NOTEBOOK THAT SHOWS WHEN YOU'RE
ON SCENE YOU'RE ON YOUR FOR THE
DAY.
AND THEN YOU'LL KNOW THEY GO TO
MAKE UP AND CERTAIN ACTORS OR
ACTRESSES WHO THINK THAT THEY'RE
MORE ESTABLISHED THAN OTHERS
TAKE THEIR TIME.
C.O.B. ONSET AND YOU'RE WAITING,
WAITING, UNDERSTAND AT LEAST
THREE OTHER PEOPLE ON THE
TOTEM POLE THE RUNNER WENT TO
GET HER, THE PRODUCTION
ASSISTANT WENT TO GET HER.
HE IS STANDING IN NEW YORK CITY
WITH CLOWN SHOES ON.
OKAY KRISTA MARK FOR THOSE OF
YOU OR ANYONE IS EVER BORROWED
MY SHOES AND TRY TO RUN AROUND
WITH THEM.
HAVE FUN.
I GUARANTEE 17, TRY.
I GOT TO THE POINT WHERE THE
STAR OF THE SHOW, IN CLOWN SHOES
WENT TO YOUR TRAILER WALK TO THE
SET, EVERYTHING IN CLOWN SHOES.
OPENS IT UP AND YELLS AT YOU
WHEN THE FACT THAT HER STORY DID
NOT END WITH LAUGHING
HYSTERICALLY IS BILL MURRAY JUST
AS A CLOWN AND IS CUSSING AT YOU
IS [BLEEP] HILARIOUS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Kat: SHE SAYS THAT IT STILL
BOTHERS HER IS THAT WHAT I HAD
TO LIE AWAKE ABOUT AT NIGHT I'D
BE SO GRATEFUL.
>> Walter: IT DIDN'T BOTHER
HER THAT MUCH.
BECAUSE SHE WAITED TO SEE IT FOR
30 SOMETHING YEARS.
>> Tyrus: AND SHE WAS LAUGHING
WHEN SHE WAS TIME TO STORY.
>> Walter: GINA DAVIS HAD A
PROBLEM, SHE NEEDED MONEY.
SHE WAS GOING TO WRITE A BOOK.
SHE KNEW THAT NOBODY REALLY
CARED ABOUT THE LIFE OF GINA
DAVIS BUT SHE KNEW THAT THEY
MIGHT CARE ABOUT BILL MURRAY.
SO SHE CAME UP WITH BILL MURRAY
WITH A PREAPPROVED STORY THERE
REALLY ISN'T THAT HARSH MEMORY
WHICH IS JUST GONNA SAY AT HER
IN A CLOWN SUIT THIS IS YOUR BIG
TRAUMA ORIGIN STORY BUT HOW SHE
BECAME THE HAS-BEEN SHE IS NOW.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: I BELIEVE THAT IN MY
LIFE JUDGING THIS I MUST HAVE 50
GINA DAVIS IS LOOKING IN MY
BACKGROUND.
BECAUSE I'VE GIVEN SO MUCH
[BLEEP] TO GUESTS, MALE AND
FEMALE IS A LOWLY GALLON?
I HATE THE LOLLYGAGGING.
>> Walter: LOOK, YOU WILL BE
FLATTERED THAT THEY REMEMBER
YOU.
>> Dagen: THE HISTORICALLY
HORRIBLE PERSON OF MEN AND WOMEN
RICHARD DREYFUS FILMED WHAT
ABOUT BOB WITH EMMA RIGHT AROUND
THE SAME TIME IN YEARS AGO TOLD
THE STORY ABOUT THEY ARE DRUNK
AT DINNER AND CAME BACK AND WAS
SCREAMING AT HIM AND SAID
EVERYONE HATES YOU YOUR
TOLERATED.
>> Greg: THAT'S AMAZING
BECAUSE IT'S TRUE.
BUT THEN THREW AN ASHTRAY AND
RICHARD DREYFUS ABOUT THE SIZE
OF THE COFFEE TABLE AND ALSO
THROUGH A PRODUCER IN THE LAKE
ON THE SAME MOVIE BUT IT'S WENT
ON AND ON AND ON SO GINA DAVIS
SHE WANT THIS PODCAST OF WHO
SHALL REMAIN NAMELESS PODCAST
HOST WHOSE OBLIVIOUS BECAUSE SHE
TRIED TO MAKE IT A CHICK THING
IT IS NOT A CHICK THING
BILL MURRAY HE IS HILARIOUS BUT
YOU MIGHT NOT WANT TO WORK WITH
THEM.
BY THE WAY REAL QUICK GREG, DO
YOU YELL ABOUT ME BEHIND MY
BACK?
>> Greg: PROBABLY.
>> Tyrus: NO, HE DOESN